at people's homes and business rooftops.
We looked at pesticide levels.
We thought there would be less pesticides in areas where bees are doing better.
That's not the case.
So what we found here in our study is -- the orange bars are Boston,
and we thought those bars would be the lowest,
there would be the lowest levels of pesticides.
And, in fact, there are the most pesticides in cities.
So the pesticide hypothesis for what's saving bees --
less pesticides in cities --
is not it.
And this is very typical of my life as a scientist.
Anytime I've had a hypothesis,
not only is it not supported, but the opposite is true.
(Laughter)
Which is still an interesting finding, right?
We moved on.
The disease hypothesis.
We looked at diseases all over our beehives.
And what we found in a similar study to this one with North Carolina State is:
there's no difference between disease in bees
in urban, suburban and rural areas.
Diseases are everywhere; bees are sick and dying.
In fact, there were more diseases of bees in cities.
This was from Raleigh, North Carolina.
So again, my hypothesis was not supported. The opposite was true.
We're moving on.
(Laughter)
The habitat hypothesis.
This said that areas where bees are thriving have a better habitat --
more flowers, right?
But we didn't know how to test this.
So I had a really interesting meeting.
An idea sparked with my friend and colleague Anne Madden,
fellow TED speaker.
We thought about genomics, kind of like AncestryDNA or 23andMe.
Have you done these?
You spit in a tube and you find out, "I'm German!"
(Laughter)
Well, we developed this for honey.
So we have a sample of honey and we look at all the plant DNA,
and we find out, "I'm sumac!"
(Laughter)
And that's what we found here in Provincetown.
So for the first time ever, I'm able to report to you
what type of honey is from right here in our own community.
HoneyDNA, a genomics test.
Spring honey in Provincetown is from privet.
What's privet? Hedges.
What's the message?
Don't trim your hedges to save the bees.
(Laughter)
I know we're getting crunchy and it's controversial,
so before you throw your tomatoes,
we'll move to the summer honey, which is water lily honey.
If you have honey from Provincetown right here in the summer,
you're eating water lily juice;
in the fall, sumac honey.
We're learning about our food for the first time ever.
And now we're able to report, if you need to do any city planning:
What are good things to plant?
What do we know the bees are going to that's good for your garden?
For the first time ever for any community, we now know this answer.
What's more interesting for us is deeper in the data.
So, if you're from the Caribbean and you want to explore your heritage,
Bahamian honey is from the laurel family,
cinnamon and avocado flavors.
But what's more interesting is 85 different plant species
in one teaspoon of honey.
That's the measure we want, the big data.
Indian honey: that is oak.
Every sample we've tested from India is oak,
and that's 172 different flavors in one taste of Indian honey.
Provincetown honey goes from 116 plants in the spring
to over 200 plants in the summer.
These are the numbers that we need to test the habitat hypothesis.
In another citizen science approach,
you find out about your food and we get some interesting data.
We're finding out now that in rural areas,
there are 150 plants on average in a sample of honey.
That's a measure for rural.
Suburban areas, what might you think?
Do they have less or more plants in suburban areas with lawns
that look nice for people but they're terrible for pollinators?
Suburbs have very low plant diversity,
so if you have a beautiful lawn,
good for you, but you can do more.
You can have a patch of your lawn that's a wildflower meadow
to diversify your habitat,
to improve pollinator health.
Anybody can do this.
Urban areas have the most habitat, best habitat,
as you can see here: over 200 different plants.
We have, for the first time ever, support for the habitat hypothesis.
We also now know how we can work with cities.
The City of Boston has eight times better habitat
than its nearby suburbs.
And so when we work with governments, we can scale this.
You might think on my tombstone, it'll say,
"Here lies Noah. Plant a flower." Right?
I mean -- it's exhausting after all of this.
But when we scale together,
when we go to governments and city planners --
like in Boston, the honey is mostly linden trees,
and we say, "If a dead tree needs to be replaced, consider linden."
When we take this information to governments, we can do amazing things.
This is a rooftop from Fred's company.
We can plant those things on top of rooftops worldwide
to start restoring habitat and securing food systems.
We've worked with the World Bank
and the presidential delegation from the country of Haiti.
We've worked with wonderful graduate students at Yale University and Ethiopia.
In these countries, we can add value to their honey
by identifying what it is,
but informing the people of what to plant
to restore their habitat and secure their food systems.
But what I think is even more important is when we think about natural disasters.
For the first time,
we now know how we can have a baseline measure of any habitat
before it might be destroyed.
Think about your hometown.
What risks does the environment pose to it?
This is how we're going to save Puerto Rico after Hurricane Maria.
We now have a baseline measure of honey,
honey DNA from before and after the storm.
We started in Humacao.
This is right where Hurricane Maria made landfall.
And we know what plants to replace and in what quantity and where
by triangulating honey DNA samples.
You might even think about right here,
the beautiful land that connected us, that primed us,
all the citizen science to begin with,
the erosion, the winter storms
that are getting more violent every year.
What are we going to do about this,
our precious land?
Well, looking at honey DNA,
we can see what plants are good for pollinators that have deep roots,
that can secure the land,
and together, everybody can participate.
And the solution fits in a teaspoon.
If your hometown might get swept away or destroyed by a natural disaster,
we now have a blueprint suspended in time
for how to restore that on Earth,
or perhaps even in a greenhouse on Mars.
I know it sounds crazy, but think about this:
a new Provincetown,
a new hometown,
a place that might be familiar that's also good for pollinators
for a stable food system,
when we're thinking about the future.
Now, together, we know what's saving bees --
by planting diverse habitat.
Now, together, we know how bees are going to save us --
by being barometers for environmental health,
by being blueprints, sources of information,
little data factories suspended in time.
Thank you.
(Applause)